le horse ball est une sorte de basket
rugby à cheval deux équipes de six
joueurs s'affrontent sur deux périodes
de dix minutes pour marquer un but dans
un panier située à trois mètres
cinquante de hauteur
l'équipe en possession du ballon doit
faire trois passes minimum
le horse ball est donc un sport
spectaculaire où parfois les contacts
sont pour le moins rugueux et pas
seulement entre chevaux à partir du
moment où on se bat on s'engage pour le
ballon effectivement il peut y avoir des
des des contacts assez virulent mais il
faut savoir que le règlement est fait
pour protéger le cheval et le cavalier
donc même quand on se penche au
ramassage donc pour ramasser les ballons
de foot les parterres normalement on est
obligé si on ramasse pas le ballon de
laisser le ramasseur tranquille pour
qu'ils puissent ramasser ballon parce
que là on est exposé au danger
effectivement avant de jouer horse ball
il faut d'abord être cavaliers et
maîtriser son cheval aux trois allures
pas trot et galop
mais ce sport est aussi exigeant pour
les chevaux ils doivent être dressés
pour ne pas avoir peur du ballon
apprendre à effectuer des courses très
rapide et s'arrêter au civil des
attitudes nécessaires pour que le couple
soit performant la complicité entre le
cheval et le cavalier je veux dire si le
cheval et le cavalier ne s'entendent pas
on a un couple qui fonctionne pas et
donc c'est difficile après un couple qui
ne fonctionne pas c'est difficile de
s'intégrer dans une équipe aussi où tout
le monde va se retrouver pour que le
collectif fonctionne correctement
dans ce derby matches s'impose face à
chambly 9 buts à 5 et assure sa montée
en championnat de france